resuelve el sistema de ecuaciones por
sustitución verifica tu solución
graficando las ecuaciones hagámoslo por
sustitución sabemos que es igual a 2x
cuadrada más 3x menos 6 y también que es
igual a menos x cuadrada estas dos yes
son la misma por lo cual entonces esto
de aquí tiene que ser igual a esto de
aquí es decir menos x cuadrada es igual
a 2 x cuadrada más 3 x menos 6 el valor
de x donde estas expresiones son iguales
nos va a proporcionar el valor de x
donde está si son iguales obtendremos
así el punto de intersección es decir la
pareja de xy que cumple con ambas
ecuaciones entonces resolvemos esta
ecuación para x empecemos sumando x
cuadrada a ambos lados de la ecuación
sumamos x cuadra ambos lados y que nos
queda del lado izquierdo nos queda 0 y
del lado derecho nos queda 3 x cuadradas
+ 3 x menos 6
podemos simplificar esto dividiendo
entre 3 a ambos lados de la ecuación
dividimos entre 3 del lado izquierdo y
dividimos entre 3
todos estos términos el lado izquierdo
nos queda 0 del lado derecho nos queda x
cuadrada más x menos 63 menos 2 ahora
aquí podríamos aplicar la fórmula
cuadrática o podríamos completar
cuadrados sin embargo esta ecuación se
puede factorizar fácilmente
buscamos aquí un par de números tales
que multiplicados nos dan menos 2 y
sumados nos dan más 1 esto se factor
hice entonces como x 2 x x menos 1 de
donde obtenemos que x + 2 es igual a
cero
x menos uno es igual a cero resolviendo
estas dos ecuaciones restando 2 ambos
lados obtenemos que x es igual a menos 2
y sumando 1 a ambos lados obtenemos que
x es igual a 1 estas son nuestras dos
soluciones x es igual a menos 2 o x es
igual a 1
verifiquemos estos valores vamos a
sustituir x igual a menos 2 en esta
ecuación vamos a ponerlo por aquí cuando
x es igual a menos 2
esto sería menos 2 al cuadrado es 4 y
este signo menos sería menos 4 así es
que cuando x es igual a menos 2 el valor
de ye correspondientes
menos 4 ahora cuando x es igual a 11 al
cuadrado 1 con el signo menos menos uno
lo que nos da el punto 1 - 1 así es que
para esta ecuación para esta función
obtenemos estos dos puntos ahora
sustituyendo x igual a menos 2 en la
ecuación de arriba veamos menos 2 al
cuadrado es 4 por 2 es igual a 8 tenemos
que es 8 más 3 x menos 2 es menos seis y
menos seis ahora 862 menos seis esto es
igual a menos cuatro así es que tenemos
el punto el punto menos 2,4 está también
en esta ecuación ambas ecuaciones
comparten ese punto se intersectan ahí
ahora sustituyendo x igual a 12
3 - 6 2 3 5 6 es igual a menos 1 hemos
sustituido el valor de x igual a 1
obtenemos entonces que el punto 1 - 1
también está en la gráfica de esta
ecuación gráfica hemos estos puntos el
punto menos 2 - 4 - 2 1 2 3 4 aquí está
menos dos menos 4 y el punto 1 - 1
aquí tenemos 1 y menos 1 hacia abajo
esos son los dos puntos de intersección
de estas dos ecuaciones graphic hemos
esta ecuación esta segunda ecuación aquí
nos lo pide verifica tu solución
verifica solución graficando las
ecuaciones vamos a graficar esta que es
fácil de igual a menos x cuadrada va a
pasar por el punto 0,0 es una parábola
que abre hacia abajo cuando x es igual a
1 o equis igual a menos 1 y es igual a
menos 1 así es que este punto también
está en la parábola cuando x es igual a
2 o menos 2 que va a ser igual a menos 4
y la gráfica se va a ver algo así 6 789
o sea ver algo así aquí está la parábola
este la gráfica de esta ecuación que
tenemos aquí ahora está va a abrir hacia
arriba esta es una parábola que abre
hacia arriba y una manera rápida
podríamos completar cuadrado y todo eso
que se puede hacer pero si lo piensas
detalladamente apliquemos la fórmula
cuadrática y te voy a mostrar una manera
rápida de encontrar el vértice cuando se
aplica dicha fórmula cuadrática al
aplicar la fórmula cuadrática para
encontrar las raíces de esta ecuación
nos da que x es igual a menos b menos 3
más menos la raíz cuadrada de de
cuadrada 3 al cuadrado que es 9 menos
cuatro menos 4 que multiplica a 2 x c x
menos 6 y todo eso dividido entre dos
veces a todo eso dividido entre 2 x 2
ahora podemos evaluar esto y encontrar
las raíces de la ecuación pero en
realidad lo que te quiero mostrar es que
si bien siempre tenemos dos soluciones
déjame escribir la fórmula cuadra
para mostrarte mi punto claramente la
fórmula cuadrática es menos b más menos
raíz de cuadrada menos 4 hace sobre 2a a
partir de esta fórmula si este número es
mayor que 0 siempre vamos a obtener dos
soluciones y son equidistantes están a
una distancia de esta cantidad sobre dos
a de menos b sobre 2a esto lo podemos
escribir como menos b sobre 2a más menos
la raíz de b cuadrada menos 4 ac sobre 2
a entonces tenemos a lo más dos
soluciones que están a la misma
distancia de este valor de x que tenemos
aquí y como hemos visto en varios vídeos
cuál es ese punto que está a la misma
distancia de las dos soluciones justo a
la mitad ahí se va a ubicar la línea
simetría o el valor de x del vértice así
es que este va a ser el valor de x del
vértice valor x de vértice es menos b
sobre 2a así es que si queremos
encontrar el valor x del vértice de esta
parábola tenemos menos b menos tres
sobre 2 x sobre 2
sobre 4 - tres cuartos es la coordenada
en x del vértice de esta parábola y
cuando x es igual a menos tres cuartos
cuanto vale y bien eso es un poquito más
complicado de hacer mentalmente voy a
desarrollar los cálculos por aquí esto
es 2 por 9 sobre 10 y 6 2 por 9
dieciseisavos menos nueve cuartos menos
seis déjame sacar la calculadora para
hacer esto a ver veamos va a ser 18
sobre 16 no no no no vamos a sacar la
calculadora va a ser más fácil lo que yo
perder tu tiempo haciendo aritmética
esto es 2 x no directamente 18 sobre 16
esto es igual a y eso menos
nueve cuartos menos nueve entre cuatro y
a eso le restamos 6 menos 6 esto nos da
menos 7.125 así es que esto es igual a
menos 7.125 así es que el vértice va a
estar en menos tres cuartos
ahí lo tenemos menos tres cuartos y
lleva a ser menos 7.125 menos siete y un
cuarto uno dos tres cuatro cinco seis
siete y un cachito más y un cachito más
para abajo
ahí está el vértice de esta parábola que
tenemos arriba lo ubicamos aquí y hay
una simetría alrededor del vértice este
sería entonces el eje de simetría por lo
que la gráfica de la ecuación de arriba
se va a ver más o menos así se va a ver
más o menos así algo así y ya hemos
concluido hemos encontrado los dos
puntos de intersección que son este y
éste y hemos verificado nuestra solución
haciendo las gráficas